and I think we shouldn't downplay uh
Plastics and endocrine disruptors I
think we should absolutely focus on that
shout out to Alex Jones who has that
famous clip where he had to turn in the
frogs gay RFK Jr actually has a similar
clip where he mentions that when you put
atrazine in the water with frogs the
frogs begin to uh yes change yeah so the
thing with atrazine though from what I
understood about it is it actually
causes physiological changes like higher
rates of micropenis uh yeah and all
types of stuff like that are we seeing
that in the human population well I'm
just saying I think I think we should
not ignore that perhaps in California
you have these people who it it I think
it's very likely to be social
um very likely but I do think there's a
strong possibility that over the past
couple of decades you've had women
ingesting all of their food wrapped in
plastic we all have been but you know
women are eating everything and this is
this is relatively new in the past
couple of generations go to an antique
shop and everything I it's crazy I went
to an antique store and they had like
orange knee-high or something metal can
yeah that's nuts thick metal can to
drink a soda and now you have women who
are ingesting all this plastic while
they're pregnant the plastic goes into
the womb and it negatively impacts the
child I'm wondering if
we could be looking at something on an
asbestos a DDT level scale where it's
praised and championed and used
everywhere and everything and then
caused massive negative uh there's a
massive a massive negative outcome and
now we know we've seen all these stories
in the news about how Plastics leech
phthalates pcbs Etc and their endocrine
disruptors
do do we just ignore that we have these
stories saying this thing is happening
and then we just
don't acknowledge I mean like we know
absolutely there's absolutely a
connection between Health across the
board and Development Across the board
and what we're eating I mean I the rate
of people with autoimmune diseases I
have two autoimmune diseases three
technically and this is unheard of
historically
um and the it you're seeing rates of
Lupus which was historically an
extremely rare rare rare autoimmune
disease the point where it was a joke on
like house house
you keep your drugs in a lupus textbook
but now now you are seeing legitimately
lupus pop up in many places
um I mean Selena Gomez has it doesn't
you yes yes she does and it's crazy
she's young and since they're bringing
house back they should actually
incorporate that into the storyline well
there there's uh an article in giant
robot ungiant freaking robot about how
they wanna that Hulu is going to be
bringing it back for a limited run I
don't know if that's possible I don't
know if you can tell those jokes now
um it's gonna be a whole other kind of I
invite everyone to go re-watch it with
modern
talking to someone who identifies
seriously a different gender well watch
no watch the episode where he has the 16
year old uh hermaphrodite I have seen
that yes
um that that is an incredible episode
but
a lot of stuff like I am always
um
I always point out to all my friends
like you should consider getting off
birth control right because birth
control is designed to disrupt women's
hormones so that's also true of plastic
that's true of a lot of things that we
celebrate we get excited about but we
ultimately find out later maybe we
shouldn't have as much of this uh we are
a society that when we have an
innovation we tend to be like it's great
use it everywhere and then later decades
later we're like oh perhaps not but
there are some things around a lot to
question so again for me the big one
that I always say to women is birth
control you should question birth
control I know for some people it's a
good thing and it can be helpful but
generally long-term birth control uh use
is uh there's a study that's out right
now which got published by Cambridge
University press uh women who start
birth control under the age of 20. so as
teenagers have are 130 more likely to
develop depression than women who do not
and then all women who start birth
control have uh higher rates of
depression than women who do not what do
we hear about people all the time I'm
lonely I'm depressed I'm having trouble
connecting with people well maybe we
should question what we're putting into
our bodies and I'm happy for that to be
food I'm happy for that to be
environmental but again I think we have
to talk about the biggest change to
women's life which is that uh 65 of
women in America are on some form of
birth of birth control typically oral
contraceptive and you couple that with
social media and how depressing again
people are becoming because of social
media and it's a perfect storm it might
not just be a singular aspect it might
be a bunch of factors coming into play
at once I mean for sure what you eat for
sure what you drink for sure what you
see on TV for sure what you absorb
through your phone what you're shown in
you know your interactions on the street
all these things yeah they have a
long-term effect on you each one is
happening now in conjunction which is
probably why we're seeing the escalation
of things so quickly because it's not a
singular factor which in itself might
have taken decades right we're seeing
tons of things together hit you and
that's why you know you might be seeing
the changes you're talking about that
might have taken 50 years of of
long-term mattressine exposure happening
over 10 years because there's this
social engineering aspect there's we
also know that uh I read this study I
think we talked about on the show there
is a birth control that women had taken
and they could still get pregnant while
on it and if they did they had a
masculinized female baby that I think
they said every one of them turned out
to be lesbians
so I I think this stuff is deeply
altering our physiology but it's not
just the Plastics or whatever
I mean the chemicals in our food in
general
words you can't even pronounce so we try
we do a lot here to get away from that
stuff we have those epic meat bars those
protein bars yeah the ingredient is like
pork salt pepper amazing beef salt
pepper Venison and uh you know we have
this here we have these uh glass bottles
that we put filtered water in re
mineralized but I think it's also a big
Pharma
these drugs so I have experience with
Bigfoot I have Crohn's disease I also
have a genetic defect which causes my
cholesterol to be like ridiculously high
and oddly enough I just did a heart scan
and I don't have evidence of
artherosclerosis which contradicts all
the knowledge we know about high
cholesterol and so there's a big shift
happening in medicine a lot of my
doctors are like hey let's maybe pull
you off not give you tons of biologics
I've luckily have good doctors and
they're like let's try the AIP diet the
you know anti-inflammatory diet get you
on clean meats that are not processed in
any way shape or form keep you away from
certain vegetables that are you know
you're not able to tolerate right now
don't eat anything processed don't eat
refined sugar keeping me on a strict
diet now I'm seeing way better results
than that but I got on a medication
called repatha uh and I'm not going to
bash this medication it lowered my
cholesterol tremendously but I ended up
and like this is incredibly rare and it
shouldn't happen on this medication at
all in the hospital with rhabdo rhabdo
is what you see like CrossFit athletes
get when they're dehydrated and
overworked your muscle is dying and it
leaks into your body and it can kill you
it can clog your kidneys and uh and so
they denied that there's any correlation
between their medication developing
rhabdo
I've been a competitive athlete my whole
life for for fighting uh I have never
developed this I didn't even do a hard
workout this time about it two days
after the injection can I say it's from
that no I would never say it's
absolutely from that but again there's
we don't know what we're putting into
our body half the time and the
pharmaceutical companies are not out for
our best interests and they benefit it
we're talking about a potential increase
in autoimmune disease and autoimmune
zenous chronic who benefits from when
you're chronically sick big Pharma they
need you as customers forever there it's
it's hard to say because I don't want to
assume the worst in everyone but if
you're in the pharmaceutical industry
curing patience is actually not in your
best interest chronic illness is a
godsend for big Pharma chronic illness
is the best it beats everything else
because you have it for your whole life
and a lot of them don't necessarily
lower your lifespan that much they just
make it very very difficult to live with
it do you think that um maybe some of
the things you're experiencing are
caused by the Pharmaceuticals or by one
million diet all right one million
percent diet one million percent died in
my life has affected me I think there's
environmental factors that have affected
me I think people don't realize the
effects of I've traveled a lot of my
life and I've lived in like different
places I've lived in places with mold
for sure black mold other things like
that and uh I'm sure that's had in
effect uh certain stressors in life can
cause an effect again if you're I think
like I said earlier I've suffered from
depression and just states of nihilism I
didn't believe in something bigger than
myself I'm sure that living in a
negative state had an impact on my
health as well a lot of people don't
acknowledge the effects that stress
depression all these things have on your
health
the mind-body connection was largely
ignored by doctors until very recently
where they said no the mind really does
have an impact on your body we do have
to take these things more seriously
long-term anxiety does increase your
risk of certain complications in life
like heart disease and things like that
so
um I think that luckily there's a shift
happening for good doctors but I also
saw during the the whole vaccine thing
how many crazy doctors marching with uh
with all the protesters you know during
the BLM really well I think we bring
this up yesterday that the it was a
Colorado Sun there are other outlets
that said the BLM protest actually
reduced the spread of code yes of course
you had a video out of New York where
the doctors are standing outside waving
and cheering for all the people Marching
In the Street there were doctors saying
like this is a worthy cause so it's
worth doing you're saying I can't go to
work but this can happen but then when
people were like it may be a worthy
cause but you're causing us harm they
went actually it looks like these are
reducing the spread of coven this is the
scariest thing in the world to me that
people can accept
such ludicrous positions I remember when
this happened I remember I spoke to my
dad when the the doctors were out
protesting with the BLM writers and my
dad said look the truth is people will
see the numbers will go up and they'll
acknowledge that these people are wrong
it won't matter because they won't
report the numbers going up and it won't
matter
they'll give it another reason it's it's
it was a trump uh rally that super
spreaded you know what you said earlier
that actually made me
that makes me a little bit upset you
said these people are just omitted
certain information and I agree they are
but on us on another level when I talk
to people that I've known for years and
I tell them hey this is what's going on
at a at some of these drag shows that
you think kids should go to here's
pictures and video they go it doesn't
matter that's not most of them that's
just that one they will rationalize
anything at this point it's not a matter
of lacking information it's a matter of
your entire identity being wrapped
around the singular ideology and that if
anyone challenges it you will always
find a way to rationalize why they are
wrong and it's okay another one remember
when um Trump left office in the in the
death counters magically went away on
all the the new sets it's just evil it's
just evil the death counters that were
never accurate I mean there were all
sorts of like very subtly slipped out
corrections after the fact I remember uh
some city in Massachusetts was like oh
we have to reduce our number by like
several thousand and one of the examples
was someone died while they had covered
but in a car accident yeah and so it was
sort of like I see so you're patting
your numbers here team like it didn't
make any sense there was Financial
benefits to that too
they would present this this information
they always there's always an appeal to
Authority look at our data and look at
these statistics but all of it is
misrepresented and wrong and so you can
never create a culture that fully at
least for a lot of people there you grow
an intense amount of skepticism they can
never trust any of these institutions
which personally I feel like is good you
should question these things on the
other hand when we need reliable
information to make informed decisions
it's not out there yeah you have two
options now you're either misinformed or
uninformed yeah and that's a scary place
to be especially with things that
involve your safety and health and we've
done something that's so dangerous just
on another deep kind of social level
which is we've taken the historical
virtues that have made societies great
like courage strength being able to
stand up in the face of adversity and
we've altered them completely and put
things like security you know don't be
scared agreeableness those are now our
highest virtues those are the antithesis
of Virtues they're not just the denial
of the other virtues they are the
opposite of them and so I mean that's
just a whole other problem in itself is
that part of a society becoming more
feminized uh agreeableness being women
being committed higher on the agreeable
scale
um and all of those other things that
you're talking about whether we're
talking about courage have some aspect
of conflict behind it a lot of the time
right have being willing to stand up for
yourself being willing to say no I'm not
going to accept this garbage story
you're telling me uh I I just wonder if
that plays at least some role in it in
the fact that a lot of it now is uh
appeal to Authority right like you don't
want to be the conspiracy theorist right
I was told that it's bad to do your own
research I was told that uh by a very
reliable source at this mainstream
Network that doing your own research is
a sign of white supremacy or something I
don't know you know but they were saying
that right they were saying you
shouldn't like now is the time there was
articles and like that we're saying now
is the time to not do your own research
yeah don't critically think the New York
Times it's bad thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time